what I said to Jordan Peterson was
actually a Dua may Allah subhana throw
him in Hellfire for what he said I meant
it I meant every word go to hell that
was a Dua for me and it's not like we
didn't know this was going to happen I
think the scale is what is shocking to
people right now The Audacity Of The
genocide that's taking place in such a
quick period of time and and the way
that it's been enabled the people of
Gazza don't have expectations of this D
they've already been primed I mean they
go to sleep truly not knowing if they're
going to wake up they literally do this
all the time so I got up there I spoke
right before the Prime Minister brudo
spoke right after me then I came to find
out I got text messages like hey you
know they cut your your stream Midway
through your speech I was talking to
someone who works at I don't want to
give up an identity at CBC but knows
like what's happening at CBC and said
yeah like they they always keep a 30
second lag so that if things go wild
they can you know move away from it so
as soon as you said Palestine cut and
what was the excuse they used technical
difficulties I want to be very real
about this this is a time for courage
how we react in this moment as a
community is going to shape the way that
this issue can be discussed for
generations to come decades to come here
so this is a time for courage my
University never lets me teach a class
again so be if I never get invited to
mainstream spaces again or if I get
kicked out of every one of those I'm
okay that's a badge of honor for us to
sacrifice for Philistine this is a time
where we B together and we don't accept
the
intimidation
[Music]
may Allah untiy no from our tongue
expand for us our chest allow us to
speak the truth allow us to be alone in
the room without the influence ofan may
Allah forgive us for any slips and
mistakes may Allah allow us to be
leaders for the men to to bring people
towards Islam and to be leaders for the
righteous welcome to the realest podcast
in the the three Muslims we are blessed
with finally being with our brother
IM how you doing today aldah he's very
tall in
person same
height give or take foot same height in
J
right
same so um something that stood out me
very recently um was your response to
Jordan Peterson um when he he tweeted to
uh in response to the October 7th attack
he said give him hell Netanyahu and he
responded by saying go to hell um I
think it was one of the first times I
I've seen you take a very staunch stance
against uh someone in public like that
and uh I think it was it for me it was
very impactful I think a lot of people
really appreciated that from you as well
so what was your response to the overall
situation so here's the the backstory to
that um on Tuesday nights I actually
teach a course called the first um at we
take one of the S and we covered the
sahabi uh for that week and I just
finished Subhan Allah funny enough the
um the lectures about the
of two massacres that took place after
after the prophet wasallam so actually
more people were killed more companions
were killed in what was a sneak attack
basically I mean the prophet s was bet
trayed that's what the was about too
right they they told the prophet sent
some ambassadors to teach us the Quran
the prophet sent some of the best sah
more people were massacred in that sneak
attack in
and Massacre then so this is right after
and the prophet wasam made Dua against
those people for a whole month every
Salah at the end of every wow so our
prophet wasam in was
saying when they were knocking in his
own helmet and they were knocking his
teeth s alaihi wasallam and they were
almost they almost were able to kill him
he still was saying may Allah forgive my
people they don't know any better but
then in and when they killed his
companions that way in such a nasty way
such a deceptive way pure betrayal um
the prophet made Dua against those
tribes five salawat for a month and so I
was having this conversation with the
community that look this is aside from
the prophet Sall alaihi wasallam that we
also need to uh look at it wasn't the
norm of the Prophet s alhi wasallam he
said I was not sent as a I wasn't sent
uh to curse people but he did make Dua
against people sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when the occasion called for it
uh so what I said to Jordan Peterson was
actually a Dua may Allah subh throw him
in Hellfire for what he said I meant it
I meant every word go to hell that was a
Dua for me because for him to say that
and we see the result and it's not like
we didn't know this was going to happen
I think the scale is what is shocking to
people right now the Audacity Of The
genocide that's taking place in such a
quick period of time and and the way
that it's been enabled by um the United
States and others but we knew that you
know it's not the first time razza gets
bomed and little children are deated
into pieces so we knew what was going to
happen and so um I meant that Dua and
and to be honest with you I think it's
it's important you know I was sharing
with with you guys on the way here that
you know it's interesting people
question the existence of a Hellfire
Hellfire is a mercy sometimes to the
oppressed to know that the oppressor
will will have to face the consequences
for the things that they say and the
things that they do and so especially in
this situation subh I mean obviously his
final H is with Allah subhana his final
judgments with Allah but um the
situation I think called for it that you
know you invoke a punishment on our
innocent brothers and sisters and so we
invoke a punishment on you in response
now me personally I I can't help but get
those those thoughts of like why doesn't
Allah just you know like destroy the
oppressors why doesn't Allah just save
you know the innocent people but
obviously Allah he he addresses that in
the Quran he mentions that he allows
these things to happen so he can take sh
he could take Martyrs um and I thought
about like from the non-muslim from the
wrongdoers perspective Allah's letting
them build a case against himself like
they're worsening the for them on the
day of judgment and that is something
that really stuck with me
so Allah will let the the oppressor
drink his own Kool-Aid think that he's
he has that power until he intoxicates
himself with that power and then Allah
subh will snatch him and Allah will not
let him go wow and that's why the the
mention your lord does not forget is a
comfort for the oppressed and is a
warning to the oppressor wow because
sometimes when a person has been
oppressed for a long time or you know
times have passed and it seems like
there was no recourse in this dun a
person might think to themselves am I
going to get my Justice or not and Allah
is saying your lord has not for
forgotten and for the oppressor the
oppressor might move on and say well
nothing happened to me I didn't get
struck by lightning I'm still living my
life your lord has not forgotten nothing
makes sense in the question of evil
especially when there are oppressed
people without the existence of the
Hereafter yeah so we're on a Continuum
of time right and so
this is a period of our existence not
our entire existence if this is our
entire existence then it's misery and
senseless but we know it's not our
entire existence and the Shaz know that
it's not their entire existence and
that's that's something that's deeply
profound is that sometimes we're having
a faith crisis that the people that are
experiencing the worst of the material
crisis are not even having you know they
themselves have more Iman experiencing
it than us watching it which is which
which is really stunning right you're
having a faith crisis here watching on
your computer on your phone they're not
having a faith crisis over there they're
having a crisis because it is savagery
and buery but they know Allah subhana
tala they're not losing their Iman so
it's important for us to to really use
this moment to strengthen our Iman you
know people remove God from the equation
because they think that's going to offer
them Comfort yeah because I can't make
sense of it therefore no one else can
make sense of it and so what does that
mean you live sh as the prophet s said
deprived you know Shi it's an
interesting word um the prophet said
when you're in your mother's womb Allah
writes you down as or as one who is
happy or one who is deprived and this
person is deprived when they're unable
to believe in something greater than
what they can see Subhan Allah it's
amazing and I mean that's something that
has really shocked me and not just me
even like you know not even Muslims just
non-muslims as well well when people
have accepted the them recently just
seeing the people of Gaza and how they
are reacting to the situation I I heard
one one um uh speaker recently he said
that his family called him and told him
you know just just just be patient the
person in Gaza called the the Canadian
family members telling the Canadian to
be patient Subhan Allah I actually want
to share Subhan Allah's story that I'd
given a talk last Tuesday or the Tuesday
before actually last Tuesday night um
about um you know are we allowed to take
a break from watching this how do we
proceed with our everyday life like are
we supposed to have weddings are we
supposed to still do our neast are we
still supposed to go to work are we
still because there's a sense of just
we're not able to live right now right
and you know I talked about the
importance of uh being avoided
heedlessness right so you don't go from
what kills the heart is you go from you
know the Reel of the dead baby to the
funny reel that makes you laugh that's
going to kill your heart or you know go
from that to like Haram to lighten up
your heart or lighten up your mood or
whatever it is you know I'm going to
take a break so I'm going to watch
something lwd and vulgar I'm going to
take a break so I'm going to go do
something that's inappropriate or
extravagance is in this time which which
in a lot of weddings there's a lot of is
Right extravagance but the prophet still
taught Society to function even in the
midst of great crisis and Subhan Allah
after I gave the talk there was a
brother froma that sent a message uh to
a relative of his in my community so
this wasn't someone directly to me but
he's in and he was saying I listened to
the talk and he
said and he said
tell from your right upon us is that we
feel Joy for your for your happiness
and from our right upon you is that you
don't forget us even in your joy that
you make Dua for us even in your joy I
read that message in it's very just very
profound like even they're still
thinking like yeah he's absolutely right
and they are Subhan Allah when you talk
about resilience the people of
Gazza one of the things that
drives Israel crazy about Gazza is that
no matter how much they have tried to
break them down
psychologically they insist upon life
you know that idea like you know Muslims
are being framed as a people that just
teach death this is teaching life the
fact that like they still rebuild their
schools they still find their Joy they
still find their ability to function
like they're not sitting around after
the air strikes usually and just you
know we give up no like they Subhan
Allah they they they rebuild and
obviously this time Allah knows how this
one's going to play out but they rebuild
and they they reconstruct and then they
they just get right back to it and
that's something that's very admirable
about the people that resilience that
they have in that regard I have a
question though what do you think causes
that difference so you have these people
who are going through everything and
they have Yim yeah but then you have
people who like us
we're watching and our faith is over
here
wavering I think that I go back to a
Hadith from the prophet Salli
wasallam I shared it
um you know when I went to the funeral
of w the six-year-old boy that was
killed in Chicago stab 26 times and they
had his kein his his coffin was covered
with the Palestinian flag and it just it
felt like very
unreal and the of the Prophet wasam
where he
said how can I find Joy when I've
seen and his lips are already puckered
to the horn and he's staring at the
Throne of Allah with his eyes fixated
like stars ready to blow waiting for the
command from
Allah means how can I have an appetite
for this D how can I have an appetite
for this world one of my um MH said
something deeply profound years ago when
when he went through a trial um I've
quoted him uh and he said the only way
this D can disappoint you is if you have
expectations of it and truly if you have
expectations of this world it will
disappoint you if you don't have
expectations of this dun it's not going
to disappoint you and and the people of
Gaza don't have expectations of this D
they've already been primed I mean they
go to sleep truly not knowing if they're
going to wake up um now all of us should
ideally be going to sleep with the idea
that we potentially might not wake up
and that should give us a certain sense
of seriousness and
attachment but I mean they they
literally do this all the time right and
so it's not like this Y is found
overnight it's generated over time IM is
built Y is built certainty is built and
established and when you have it over a
long period of time then you're able to
to Really withstand uh in the long run
Subhan Allah you know there's another
Hadith of prophet if if if you know it
please jump in and say for me I don't
remember the full Hadith but Prophet was
telling the sahab about you know there
will come a time um and I forget the
exact Hadith but obviously not not a
great time for the Muslims and they
asked will this be because um we're
small in numbers and the prophet said
said he said no you're going to be
numerous but you're going to be like
like rubbish basically to to the
non-muslims and they're going to be
killing you say we're going to be like
the the fo that's yeah but that's a
separate Hadith but yeah he did say that
and we are like that nowadays and I mean
at least to me that's what it seems like
so so he said like but you're going to
be like the scum and like the rubbish
you know to these people and he
mentioned that Allah in this time he
will take the fear of the Muslims out of
the hearts of the enemies so they won't
fear us they won't care about us we're
like nothing to them and then he says
that in in the hearts of the Muslim is
going to be two things he said there's
going to be love of the D and fear of
death right and yeah and that's the
exact almost the exact opposite of what
you know the people in have just like
you were saying no they don't expect
much from life and for them death is
just you know it's a step towards J
inshallah martydom for them and their
people seeing the resilience W is it
makes me want to cry these people may
Allah bless them and and and free and
liberate them is it's beautiful so I did
a lecture called The Living Martyrs in
the hospitals of Gaza because I actually
was just looking at the rather they're
alive rather they're alive rather
they're alive like what made us
different in this regard right is that
they
they know that something else exists
beyond the S so they have something that
their enemy does not have and because
they know that something exists Beyond
this life they don't cling on to this
life in a way that in inspires
cowardice or
hesitation because they see it as a
necessary
step and Subhan that idea of when the
prophet is talking about
like you love this D too much and you
uh you start to hate
death it's these two things are are
inherently tied to each other if you go
to a graveyard to visit one of the sun
of the Prophet wasallam is to go and
visit to remind yourself of death you go
make du for the deceased and you remind
yourself of death right does Muslim
graveyard or any well so that's an
interesting situation uh especially when
we live amongst non-muslims
obviously the Dua that you would make
for the believing Souls when you walk in
to a Muslim graveyard things of that
sort but uh if you're driving by or
you're walking by and you see a
graveyard it's a graveyard period and
that's a tance for you to actually sit
and to remember Allah no but certainly
visiting the the graveyard uh is is uh
something that instills in us a reminder
of death and the prophet Salli wasallam
said I used to forbid you from visiting
the graves because in the original part
of Islam Prophet sallai wasam wanted the
uh Creed to settle in to people's hearts
so there are a lot of practices that
take place around and sub even now right
a lot of practices and stuff that take
place around the graves and around death
so for the majority of Islam the only
time you went to the graveyard was when
you were burying someone and then in the
last three years the prophet Sall alaihi
wasallam said I have I used to forbid
you from visiting the graves but now
visit them because it reminds you of
death so when you make Dua for the
deceased whether you make Dua for the
deceased from your home or next to the
person's grave it's going to reach
inshallah Tal for that person the
benefit will reach of what you're doing
but visit and that will remind you insh
of death cuz you need that reminder so
the people of
Gazza their whole their whole city is a
graveyard right now so the appetite of
this Dy will reduce in a person now with
that being said Subhan Allah the prophet
s still used to smile all the time the
prophet wasam still like he wouldn't
come home and and hit the floor and like
you know
I I have no no desire for for my spouse
I have no desire for food I have no no
like in just talk about death the
prophet sallai wasallam still was able
to live a full life in that sense but he
never lost perspective and what Allah
warns us from is heedlessness when you
become heedless of Allah and heedless of
the reality of this life then you're
going to become a victim of it you'll
become beholden to it the D
this world is the prison of the
believer and it is the J cath it is the
paradise of the
disbeliever why because if you know for
us no matter what goodness we experience
here we expect a greater goodness right
and for the wicked one right no matter
what goodness they experience here what
comes next is going to be worse IM was
one day walking I Haj is a very famous
scholar in Islam he was one day walking
and he was in Egypt and he had like a
really nice outfit he used to dress
nicely he was he was relatively well off
one of the greatest scholars in the
history of Islam and he was walking in
the marketplace and there was a a person
who wasn't Muslim who saw him uh walking
and this person was like sort of a more
simple person and he said to he said
didn't your Prophet wasam say that uh
this life is a Jenna for the disbeliever
and a prison for the believer and he
said yes and he said what type of jna am
I in and what type of prison are you in
like look at you and look at me that
doesn't look like a prison and this
doesn't look like a paradise and
responded he said what I expect from
Allah subhana wa tala in comparison to
this
dun this dun is a prison wow and what
you can expect from Allah subh in
comparison to this dun this is a jna for
you so the Hereafter is the GameChanger
it is the equalizer for us as believers
in happiness and in sadness in hardship
and in ease in life and in death we're
always programmed to think about what we
want in
the you want something different from
Allah than them you expect something
different from Allah so that should give
you a different type of heart and a
different type of firmness and
steadfastness as you as you you know
live your your life insh in accordance
with the hopes of the Hereafter Subhan
Allah but you said and forgive me for a
second but you said that uh something
that these brothers and sisters have is
that you know they know they after
what's coming after is much better than
what is now but what if now this
so-called enemy they also too believe
and this after and they believe that
it's only for them like what
then you know what Allah says because
that will come right at some point
you'll find two groups of people that
are
fighting uh against each other that
believe in different you know things and
different types of uh you know
dispensations in in the Hereafter um
Allah
[Music]
says so there are people that have taken
Partners besides Allah subh they love
them the way they should love Allah but
the way you love
Allah the Believers love Allah so much
more than what anyone else loves
anything else okay so whatever
attachment that anyone has garnered to
anything else the believer's attachment
to Allah subhana wa tala is greater than
that
attachment therefore it will yield more
in this life and in the next so when
when we believe in Allah and we believe
in the
Hereafter right it's it's greater than
the belief that anyone else has it
should be greater than the belief that
anyone else else has so do you really
think
that believed in his idols the way that
believed in Allah absolutely not right
absolutely not so it's it's the way we
love Allah should be different than the
way that anyone else loves anything
else she you were briefly mentioning
something that happened in Canada do you
want to go into that story yeah uh we
talk out with Trudeau with Trudeau so
Canadian so we're going to let me just
face towards uh
I used to be
Canadian no we were I think we were
talking about um a lot of the things
that are happening right now and you
know even today's is about like
hypocrisy and betrayal and the double
standards right The Masks are falling
from the so-called human rights
Defenders of the world The Masks are
falling from those that preach um you
know Superior moral ground The Masks are
falling all over the place right it's
very interesting because um in London in
Canada people think London UK London
Canada there was a Muslim family that
was run over by a uh hateful man may
Allah have mercy on them all so an
islamophobe basically ran them over with
his car his whole family may Allah
accept them all the sh and it shook the
community and I had gone for the one
year um you know uh so it happened in
coid time so it was everything was shut
down so they wanted to obviously have an
event against hate so it was one year
after the the incident took place uh so
I went to London and
um prime minister Trudeau was coming I
didn't know he was coming uh and the
reason why they didn't share that he was
coming in advance I guess is because
they have something called the trucker
protests in Canada so like he couldn't
even announce at that time I guess it
had gotten so significant where he was
going to be in advance so next thing I
know I find out he's going to be sitting
next to me so I'm like all right my
speech is going to become about not just
islamophobia here but it's going to
extend to festine and at that time India
was was India by the way still is a deep
problem what's happening in India is
very much so tied to what's happening uh
to the Palestinians because uh Hind and
andm are two twin ideologies
and is very much so learning from you
know Theo Playbook uh even bulldozing
homes and things of that sort so I said
to myself all right here's my
opportunity I'm going to go up there I'm
going to talk about Palestine and and
India and sort of the global uh hatred
of Muslims and how that all stems from
the same thing CU you can't claim to be
against the hatred of Islam and Muslims
here but then frame Islam and Muslims in
such a hateful way around the world with
both your words and your
policy so I got I said all right B here
we go so I got up there I spoke right
before the Prime
Minister uh started off talking about
the hatred obviously that that took the
lives of that family and then extended
it to Palestine extended it to India I'm
thinking to myself all right this is
great National Canadian broadcast insh
tal we finally broke through got the
message across uh the Prime Minister
spoke right after me TR spoke right
after me and then I came to find out I
got text messages like hey you know they
cut your your
stream uh Midway through your speech so
I was talking to someone who uh works at
I don't want to give up an identity at
CBC but knows like what's happening at
CBC and said yeah like they they always
keep a 30 second lag so that if things
go wild they can you know move away from
it so as soon as you said Palestine cut
right that immediately cut you off and
then the stream came back and what was
the excuse they used technical
difficulties or whatever it is selective
technical difficulties so the censorship
is is is significant right and
especially we're seeing it right now
with
um Subhan Allah what I'm what I'm
encouraged by though honestly speaking
what I'm encouraged by is right now
we're under the weight of the entire
Western political establishment all
Legacy mainstream media and social media
companies are like you know sh Banning
our pages and like taking down our stuff
constantly and still still public
opinion is actually shifting on festine
yeah because people people are still
finding ways to expose themselves to
what's actually happening in Palestine
so the weight of that establishment and
the weight of all of that money that is
thrown towards um you know uh
dehumanizing the Palestinians
alhamdulillah I think that we are making
strides and and bringing awareness to
what's actually happening over there
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah so my
question now is people hear about what's
happening they learn the truth what
should the Muslims I want I guess I want
to focus on be doing in this time what
what would you say is the obligation
upon the Muslim
Community so there are multiple
obligations or multiple ways to be
impactful depending upon your particular
circumstances yeah um obviously it
starts with a Dua it starts with a Dua
Dua is the of the believer no one can
cut your access to Allah subhana in Dua
no one can cut the access of the people
of to Allah with their
Dua to to to actually immerse yourself
in sincere
supplication as you plead to the one who
has more power than anyone or anything
that you would appeal to to make
change is your greatest obligation to
your brothers and sisters in right now
so exert yourself in Dua
and do not belittle your Dua the
potential of your Dua to actually Change
the World um you know Shan can kind of
play with their heads and say what's my
Dua going to do for these people right
they're so much righteous more righteous
than me but it may be that Allah uses
your Dua as a spark as a catalyst for
something that is changed so that's that
and on a spiritual level because we're
spiritual people um you know or we see
the the role of of spirituality in all
of this as well to fix yourself to to
rectify yourself is very important um
because you're a part of this Muslim
body and if you're the weak weak part of
the body then you're not helping the
other part of the body that's in pain
right now so hold your weight you know
strengthen strengthen your part of the
body your sins affect the body right and
your righteousness strengthens the body
hold your weight you know you're part of
the body um you know you guys look like
you work out so when you uh when when
you lift there are certain muscles that
get worked out by extension that
sometimes are not listed on the machine
right but that that helps strengthen the
entirety right so where are you on the
body and then strengthen your part of
the body right and hold your own in that
sense I think after that it's learning
educating yourself about the reality
because you need to you need to be
equipped well equipped to take on some
of the arguments that you're going to
get um so so that you don't just get
into emotional um manipulative you know
exchanges in your workplace or whatever
it is right actually educate yourself on
the history of Palestine I'd recommend
there's the 100e war on Palestine by
Rashid KH it's very very easy way to
sort of get get yourself caught up to
speed but read a bit about the history
of what's happened there uh read the
apartheid reports by by Human Rights
Watch and amnesty about why Israel is
indeed an apartheid state uh so you can
be well equipped because they want to
freeze you into October and you're like
no this is 75 years so educate yourself
so that you can be more equipped when
you're having these types of uh
discussions um get involved in your
local efforts uh to to try to bring
about awareness obviously you're
bringing awareness online in but if
there are means of peaceful protest
means of um means of of putting pressure
in different ways in that work within
the collective they do matter so involve
yourself in that uh boycott I think I
think that there's something to say
about not just the Muslim ability or or
people of you know people who are
engaged in this to say like I'm not not
going to buy I'm going to sacrifice this
particular product and we're going to do
that collectively because this company
has shown absolutely no regard for um
for for our brothers and sisters lives
and so uh we'll sink that company
economically uh the BDS Movement by the
way the boycott divestment sanctions
movement it's a very powerful movement
there's a reason why there are
anti-boycott laws on on the books of 38
states in the United States because yeah
Israel fears the the BDS movement fears
the concept of of boycott um because it
it's it's it's a viable economic power
that people can can collectively
exercise that can have meaningful
consequences um you know when it comes
to when it comes to these uh these
companies and stuff like that so there's
something even like you know if you you
know with your kids right so my kids get
really annoyed about some of the things
that we can't do anymore we can't buy
anymore but it's like hey look you see
these kids dying in Gaza you have an
obligation to them you got to nurture
that in them early on on with your kids
you know my kids are young but they they
understand enough my older two at least
like hey look like we're going to feel a
little bit of a pinch and we're going to
give up some conveniences because we
want to be we want to help the cost
don't say well we're just two people
we're just no no that's if the if if
people take on Collective action then it
can have um very meaningful um
consequences
in and keep raising awareness however
you do I think there are targeted then
there are specific ways that we can
protect ourselves in and um and advocate
for our brothers and sisters in
Palestine M uh we can build capacity so
not everyone has the the
the the leeway and their employment to
be able to to go to certain places some
people have certain skills right now we
need to legally protect our ability to
call out Israel for what it is without
facing consequences right so if you can
build capacity legally build capacity
legally punish politicians you know uh
you know with in the ways that hurt them
politically whatever it is that you have
insh try to build capacity and make
change so she I was going to ask you an
important question before we even get to
that stage how does the average lay man
overcome this whole walking on exells
type of mentality where we fear losing
our jobs We Fear getting kicked out of
uni We Fear our banks bank accounts
being closed we feel being put put
behind
bars so those are very different things
right like that's a broad spectrum that
you just mentioned mhm but you know I
want to be very real about this
um this is a time for courage this is a
time for courage this is a time for
courage how we react in this moment as a
community is going to potentially shape
the way that this issue can be discussed
for generations to come decades to come
here so this is a time for courage uh
this is a time where we B together and
we don't accept the intimidation I get
it it's easy for me to say right I I I I
work at Yen so I mean I'm not going to
inah get fired for Yen for from Yen for
being pro Palestinian uh my University
never lets me teach a class again so be
it I I'm okay with that if I never get
invited to mainstream spaces again or
whatever if I get kicked out of every
one of those I'm okay that's a badge of
honor for us to sacrifice for Philistine
right uh but at the end of the day I'm I
I also recognize that that I'm not
putting my my bread and my and and my my
my butter on the line here CU this isn't
really financially costly I do feel for
people that you know have gotten into
med schools and that have gotten you
know far in their careers um that want
to speak but that have been deeply
intimidated I think there are a few ways
around that number one um just a
principle if you can't speak the truth
then don't speak falsehood that's number
one this is a principle that we have if
you can't speak the H don't speak B so
do not um sign your name or or or
participate in anything that's actually
going to undermine um you know your
faith in this regard this is is not just
true for Philistine this is true for for
beyond that right different things
number two weigh the effectiveness of
your speech number three there strength
in numbers a lot of the people that get
fired it's because they went on social
media and they just went off on their
Instagram story it probably wasn't that
effective in the moment right but if you
found six seven people in your
department or you know in your in your
you know workplace and you put out some
sort of an internal you know memo and
then an external statement that look we
you know
we're outraged by Palestinian suffering
right now a very well- worded wellth
thought out statement then that's
probably more effective and it can
become precedent for other you know
types of spaces where other students in
different universities are trying to
fight back or other um staff members in
different companies are trying to fight
back right so be smart and effective um
but be courageous so be smart and
effective but be courageous this is not
a time to back down um now if you get to
a point where it's like look um you know
I can I can by by playing a little bit
more of a a timid role to an extent not
speaking bed but maybe not speaking as
forcefully as I can but I'm I'm I'm
making some moves within this very
important space to where I can usher in
the ability for people to speak um in a
stronger way then then alhamdulillah but
do it with SH do it with sincerity
consult so we do need to be effective so
I I don't want people to like we live in
we live in a world unfortunately where
like something you tweeted out when
you're 14 can ruin your life when you're
40 it's pretty crazy uh when you think
about it right 25 30 years old and you
get somewhere in life and you and then
someone pulls out an old post an old
tweet and you're done right so you know
we have to we have to be smart yeah we
have to be strategic but we have to be
courageous this is a time for courage uh
not a time for us to back down and
accept the intimidation so now speaking
about courage a lot of brothers and
sisters have been at the Forefront of
these protests and there's sh issuing
fatawa saying free mixing
all this type of stuff you know what are
your thoughts on
that I think that look there there are a
few things number one not everyone has
to be in every
space okay so that's number one number
two I think the Dynamics in certain
countries are going to be different um
so for example the implication of that
like in London a lot of the mash joined
that protest a lot of good Brothers
joined that protest it was a i we all
saw the scenes of that protest around
the world and the people of Gaza saw the
scenes too by the way they were
circulating it in Palestine like 500,000
people 300 to 500,000 people on the
London Bridge all over is is incredible
right
so they obviously like can't you know
separate things out or they can't
completely make that protest um you know
according to as a whole you know what
would fall in the guidelines
uh of of the Shar um but you know they
kind of carve their space out they kind
of March as a contingency you know you
speak and then you kind of leave um
bring sort of an Islamic flavor to it um
you know where it's in a substantive way
not just like a a cover to it but in a
substantive way um Dua and and changing
changing your your part of that
environment right like this is very
different from a Muslim country you know
uh I don't there isn't a single
large protest in the west that is not
going to have some objectionable
elements that are mix that are mentioned
here right so it is a judgment call um
it is something that people have to
engage very thoughtfully and thoroughly
um it is something where you know for me
I think that
um and this is I'm saying this with with
the full recognition that I could be
wrong and and may Allah subhana T
correct me if that is the case um the
moment right now that we're
in is so crucial especially again
because as loud as the political and
media establishments have been with the
Zionist
narrative the streets are fighting back
in the sense that that the the loudness
of the streets the images the the the
voice of of of normal people um is is
really giving something back it's
pushing back we we want we want to save
people's lives right now like let it's
not this is not a small inconsequential
thing so when there's something that's
effective in doing so not in not in and
of itself but in in concert with a bunch
of other actions inshallah tal um I
don't think it's wise to forsake the
space all together what I'd recommend to
to Muslims to do is when you engage
these spaces try to have conversations
with the organizers in advance uh try to
make the religious accommodations as
much as possible in advance um you know
one thing that that like uh in I'm going
to be heading to the DC protest it's
organized by a coalition of more organ I
mean organizations I've never even heard
of right but you know it starts at 2
o'cl I spoke to the organizer I said
look can we do can we pray because it
would be very powerful you're going to
have tens of thousands of people can you
make the arrangement for us to
pray um in thousands of people praying
right
and uh the prayer on the SH now there's
a difference on
of When you pray upon the deceased from
from afar but it is far superior to the
candle lights and things of that sort
right like I'd rather that we do
when passed away in Chicago and we did a
visual instead of doing like the
candlelight visuals where there could be
some objection uh to it from a Shar
perspective so why don't we just all
pull up a image of and hold up the phone
right so that that the imagery of
everyone holding up a picture of the boy
on their phone um is far more impactful
generally people are going to be
receptive insh um when they see that
you're you're genuine you're sincere
you're trying to uh you're trying to
engage in a way that's that's thoughtful
you're not going to be able to control
everything that everyone's going to say
everything like if you're on that London
Bridge you better believe that there's
going to be a a part of that whole thing
that's going to go you know in a
direction that you have no
Anticipation by the way there paid
actors as well in these protests 100% in
one of the protests there was a lady
like an elderly lady that was holding a
sign that was very like um like it's
let's just I don't even want to repeat
what was on that sign but it was it was
near to to almost like a Nazi type
message you know she didn't make the
sign herself and it was meant I mean I
knew that she didn't make the sign
herself and actually confirm she's like
someone paid her she's like an older one
of those ladies that begs paid her to
hold up the sign so then right-wing
media can capture it put it on run it
this is what these protests are really
about so you take away from what 10,000
people were saying and you focus on the
one woman that was holding a sign that
you gave her and you paid her to hold up
so there are paid actors paid
infiltrators paid agitators that's one
element of this another element is that
there are just people that don't come to
this from an Islamic place right there
are especially now a lot of Jewish uh
anti-occupation groups right if not now
Jewish voice for peace are like staging
like civil disobedience in different
places right like they're taking over a
state
and um you know and and the moment calls
for that type of stuff right now so I'd
say be careful try to go with a group
not alone try to talk to the organizers
in advance try to carve out the space
inshallah t as much as you can and I I
believe that the moment in the west
right now that this is one powerful tool
that we have at our disposal that works
in concert with with other things um so
that doesn't mean that we should
completely you know uh just immerse
ourselves in what's there but we also
shouldn't seed the space and and neglect
the whole concept because it is a
powerful tool that's at our
disposal at one point you said that one
of the things that we as Muslims can do
is s
Dua but the question that I want to
bring up here and I'm pretty sure a lot
of Muslims have this is how can you get
to the place of a sincere Dua all the
time cuz a lot of times you know you
still might feel strongly about
something but then you feel like you're
making Dua and it's it's almost like you
feel like a hypocrite because you're not
as
sincere you know
something I could be wrong in my
assessment here but if I was to guess I
would believe that more Muslims are
finding the ability to cry now than ever
before that people are able to really
cry shed tears and that's one of the
means of in to be broken in front of
Allah subhana t one of the means of a
sincere
Dua um I mean these are unspeakable
atrocities man like like you see a few
images you you see a few videos and they
absolutely Break Your Heart Right
so be broken in front of Allah be broken
in front of
Allah Allah that no one can change a
situation and no one has actual power
except Allah
subana
so the prophet said call upon Allah
while you're certain in the answer so be
certain in the answer as you're calling
upon Allah subhana tala and also know
that the one that you are calling upon
has far more power than anyone else that
is being invoked to intervene and anyone
else that is carrying out the aggression
so know who you're talking to in Allah
know his names know his
attributes but take your Brokenness to
him like don't just wipe your tears
verbalize a Dua as soon as as you start
crying put the phone down make Dua um be
broken in front of Allah it's one of the
greatest ways that a Dua can be accepted
is that a person humbles himself and is
broken in front of a l so that's why I'm
saying don't do things that Harden the
heart I think that people will say like
uh again like oh man like I need a break
from this I'm going to go watch this
show n don't do that not that all shows
are ad saying but like in general like
the you know what the implication is I'm
going to go do something that's going to
make me just completely get my mind off
my decompress my decompressing always
involves you know the opposite of what
my my concern is don't do that uh go to
the Quran this is the time to
reestablish a relationship with the
Quran Allah
says that we reveal from the Quran was a
cure and it is a mercy to the Believers
one of the benefits of that ay is it a
it is a healing for you and it descends
as an individual and it descends mercy
upon the collective of the Believers so
just reading Quran like decompressed by
reading Quran too and then make Dua
right so I think take your Brokenness to
the one who mends all things take your
pain to the one who heals all things
just take it to
Allah and W I'm serious like here's how
I actually mentioned this and I wasn't
going to mention but I couldn't help
myself because there was
like there was a moment where the Shan
almost got me
I was about to make Dua and I was like
who am I to make Dua when these blessed
people are making du what's my Dua going
to do like why even add it on to the
mix but I realized I was like he's
trying to disconnect me from making my
Dua so don't belittle the deed and don't
belittle yourself because you're calling
upon Allah so take it to
Allah that's a very good point subh
Allah CU I think at the end of the day
it's not about us really it's about
Allah you know um obviously we have to
have sincerity as you mentioned we have
to come to Allah from a sincere place
and and really mean and have you know
certainty in what we're saying but at
the end of the day it's
like as long as it's a good believing
Muslim who's making Dua like it's Allah
in the day you know and a pardon me
almost wants to say that like if you're
doubtful of that Dua who are you really
doubting you are Allah there so may
Allah protect us and keep us safe I
think unfortunately Allah would love to
keep going it's an honor having you with
us but fortunately we uh have an event
to catch we found out that we're related
yeah Subhan Allah quickly talk about
that I know it's maybe quickly this is
now my myo not
anymore like Uncle oh not his direct
Uncle obviously but uh no so usually you
know when you meet people from Palestine
you say where are they from they they
mention these Villages that are usually
around ra so they'll say
these I never hear anyone say taram so
when I asked him I said where you from
he said oh Palestine T I looked at him
like are you are you serious and I
actually know like so our families are
are are are within a connected um you
know Circle so he's he's going to be
he's my he's my cousin at some way uh
he's going to be somewhere in in the
mix we're going to see Ramy at thean
family gatherings
now are related and yall are the same
height yeah man something in something
in the water and to cut him that our
parents right Giant
Allah make us all Giants of the and be
Unapologetic in defending our brothers
and sisters in Philistine do we uh
brother om before we wrap this up do do
we want to make a quick Dua absolutely
absolutely when you
are all Praises are due to Allah subhah
waala the one who has all might the one
who has all power the one who is
irresistible the one who is
indestructible and we bear witness of
Allah that there's no power no ability
to change except that which is with you
all Praises are due to Allah who sent us
our beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallah
alaihi wasallam with divine
revelation with a guide for us in our
individual lives and our community lives
all Praises are due to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala who never fails in his promise
Allah who never betrays his
promise you have promised our brothers
and sisters a sh you have promised our
brothers and sisters Victory so long as
they stay firm y we ask you to grant our
brothers and sisters shahada and to
grant them victory yeah Allah we ask you
to protect them from above them from in
front of them them from behind them from
their right and from their left and we
ask you to make the ground firm beneath
their feet yeah Allah we ask you to
descend tranquility and firmness and
steadfastness upon their hearts yeah
Allah and we ask you to provide for them
where other people have cut them off we
ask you to heal them where other people
have hurt them we ask you oh Allah that
you allow them to be elevated in their
rank in the Hereafter and elevated in
Victory in this life yeah Allah and we
ask you to show us an example in the
oppressors oh Allah show us a miracle in
how you deal with them we ask you Ya
Allah to destroy those who oppress them
to restrict the harm of those who harm
them Ya Allah Ya Allah Ya Allah let
their own plans betray them let their
own plots betray them Ya Allah they plan
and you plan and you are the best of
planners Ya Allah let their plans betray
them let their plans betray them and we
ask you for forgiveness for all of the
believing men and the believing women
the the weak ones the downtrodden ones
wherever they are we ask you to Grant
Victory to the oppressed the ones that
we know and the ones that we don't know
and we ask you to gather us all in J
with our beloved Prophet
s with the with the with the with the
prophets along our prophet wasam and
what a blessed company that
is man I'm tearing up
too may Allah bless everybody for tuning
in inshallah she we got to do this again
sometime soon how does the average
Muslim find out more about you where can
they head uh they can head to y
institute.org or the YouTube channel
aldah I know you guys just recorded Imam
Tom so Imam Tom's doing some great stuff
there too alhamdulillah and we have a
lot of our um you know uh presenters
doing some really important stuff to
give perspective on Philistine
especially in this moment so subscribe
to our channel
in and we'll we'll keep uh doing what we
can together right now is a moment of
unity and so may Allah unite our ranks
unite our hearts and allow to be used in
useful ways for our brothers and
[Music]
sisters bless you and elev
you everyone for tuning in may Allah
bless you all immensely please please
please share it with everyone and anyone
who you can post it on your social
medias to get the message out again we
thank our beloved IM om for joining us
may Allah bless him and um everyone for
that amazing D comment #m if you made it
this far and we'll see you on the next
one
Castel